time to test a new pesto sauce and a
spread they're both vegan containing no
meat or other animal products like eggs
or milk and they need specially
developed and tested spice mixtures each
year avo brings out about a dozen new
products the boss himself is on hand for
the taste test organic foods is a big
growth market for his company when you
feel we've developed a number of vegan
products which are substitutes for meat
or sausage of course we've also
developed the spice mixtures for these
products finding the ingredients isn't
always easy that fits of a shopping
buddy mother I thought pepper for
instance the prices are high up to 14
euros a kilo so avo cooperates with a
number of farms in Sri Lanka it buys
organic pepper from an aid organization
and then pays about 50 people in a
village to process it that's the only
way the company can make sure it has a
steady supply and stable prices remain
isn't it wound up again the amounts are
limited in the organic sector there can
be shortages due to poor harvests it's a
big problem if something's in short
supply in spice compounds in which every
ingredient is supposed to be organic avo
is the market leader in Germany and
conventional spice mixtures and
marinades for cooking sausages roast
steaks and chicken it sales last year
were a hundred and eighty million euros
the spice baker wants to be a big player
in the dynamic organic food sector one
and a half percent of avo spice sales
are currently for organic products it
wants to grow that business to nine
percent the organic products are
expensive but the boss thinks they'll
sell well Debbie Stevenson marked target
does not fall down that much the market
is changing and we're convinced that our
organic products are top quality and of
course we see the growing market from a
business point of view the demographic
trends mean that more and more consumers
are in the market for organic products
and we intend to meet that demand oh
entiendo WS a whole 12 Tom mr. via in we
live in our minds ultimatum
the company sells its spices and
marinades primarily in Europe but its
sales are strong in Canada and South
America as well